JARED: Hi, I'm Jared,
software engineer for Glass.
I'm going to talk to you
about localizing Mirror API
Glassware.
What is mirror API Glassware?
Mirror API Glassware
uses the Mirror API
to push static content to
Glass through a RESTful API.
The cards appear on
Glass in the timeline,
but the way content
is pushed is different
than a traditional website.
For a traditional website,
when a request comes in,
it's easy to determine
what language
to use to show your content.
You might use the
Accept Language Header,
geolocate the request
IP, have a user setting,
or any combination of
the above, and then
return localized content.
But with a Mirror API, you don't
have incoming request headers,
or even an incoming request.
You're pushing
content to the API,
and you want that content
to be in the same language
as the rest of
Glass for that user.
So, mirror API now supports
HTTP GET for user settings.
And the first thing
is called locale.
To get the user locale, you make
a request to the Mirror API.
Here's how it works.
You request the setting
locale, and the API
returns a locale string
to you such as EL.
You can then produce and
push your timeline item
using whatever templating
technology you like,
using that locale
string to select
the appropriate translation.
There are lots of
internationalization pitfalls
that you should be aware of, for
instance, hard coded strings,
truncated text, time
formatting, et cetera.
These issues are
basically the same
whether you're writing web apps,
Android apps, or GDK Glassware.
But the mechanisms for
solving them are different.
Localizing Mirror
API timeline items
is very similar to
localizing web applications.
In fact, you can probably
use the same facilities
you're already using
for your web apps.
Maybe you use Rails, Angular,
Django, or Closure Templates.
These frameworks
all have mechanisms
for localizing your content.
Use those mechanisms
the same way you would
for traditional web content.
It's really straightforward.
Once you're pushing
localized content,
you probably don't want to
perform a GET to settings
locale for every timeline item.
That would double
how many requests you
make against Mirror
API and burn your quota
with unnecessary requests.
Instead what you can do
is subscribe to changes
in the settings collection,
similar to the way
you subscribe to Timeline
or Location Updates.
Now whenever someone changes
their language for Glass,
you'll get a notification
callback, which tells you
it's time to get the
locale setting again
and store the new
value for that user.
So you want to subscribe
to Settings Changes.
And when you get a
change notification
you retrieve the
locale for that user.
And whenever you
want to push content,
you just use the locale
string that you've already
retrieved and remembered,
and depending on your app,
you may want to refresh
existing timeline
items to reflect
the new language.
After you've localized either
your Mirror API Glassware
or GDK Glassware, submit it
to the Glass Team for review.
You should specify
all the languages
that your Glassware
supports, so we can show it
to users who speak
that language.
You can see how easy it is
to localize your Mirror API
Glassware and reach more users.
Watch for announcements
from Glass Team
for upcoming language
support in Glass.
Thanks.